57 million young people demanding change
you know it's why we're up here at cop
26 today it's youth day
we represent an incredible worldwide
force for good of young people who want
to see their future and their planet
protect it you know and it's a very
powerful voice you know young people are
always going to be the driving force of
this you know they want to do the right
thing they are super climate aware and
environmentally conscious
and it's it's wonderful to see and and
we're all up here hoping that ultimately
the leaders of the world affect change
now actually you know not not talk but
action
and uh and and there are some signs that
this is happening now it's almost like
we're past the
the point of no return we have we have
no choice now we have to do the right
thing and put some proper measures in
place to you know get rid of these
fossil fuels invest in renewables and
properly protect our forests and our
oceans i mean it's it's difficult when
you look at the
the scale of this so isn't it because i
mean a lot of your members now will be
your parents their own children may be
in the scouting movement by the time
some of these things come on board i
mean it's a level of acceptance i guess
is it that i mean some phasing out
fossil fuels for example is not going to
happen overnight
it's not but you've got it's about
making the right decisions all of us
want to be able to look our
grandchildren and stuff in the eyes one
day and say you know at the critical
time we stood up and we were counted and
we said you have to do this
and uh
you know it's not just a sort of a nice
add-on you know this is about the future
of our planet and it is these young
people's future and you know 57 million
young people young scouts around the
world is a
formidable
you know it's a formidable kind of army
really of young people saying please
please please to our leaders of the
world put these measures in place and do
the right thing i mean it's interesting
with the scouting movement in a way
because it's
you know there is so much in scouting
which is based in nature so that that
sort of survival part of what we do i
mean this there's so much more about
understanding how nature works so it's
all part of the sort of curriculum isn't
it
it is and it has been for 120 years you
know or 112 years now we've been around
you know
there was actually conservation badges
for scouts back in the 50s you know in
the in the 30s they were doing gardening
and farming and learning
about you know how to look after bees
and the animals and you know so you're
right this sort of environmental
awareness has been part of the scouting
agenda long before it was niche long
before was trendy and long before where
we are now where it's essential you know
this is this isn't about any of those
things this is ultimately now about
survival and i feel incredibly proud
that so many young scouts
are driving this and that people
hopefully up at cop 26 now are listening
it is a phenomenal movement and what i'm
i'm so proud to be uh to have been part
of in a very small way back in my youth
it's really good to talk to you bear
thank you
no hey once a scout always a scout
i'll take that